[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv 78 nouvelle édition du
7 8 hebdo et vous le voyez nous avons
quitté notre plateau de guyancourt pour
venir ici porte de versailles à paris où
se déroule le mondial de l'automobile ce
sera jusqu'au 14 octobre quasiment tous
les constructeurs sont présents comme
tous les deux ans et le département des
yvelines étant le premier département
automobile de france il était logique
que nous venions leur rendre une petite
visite voici à les titres de cet hebdo
dorénavant baptisée paris motor show le
mondial de l'auto fête ses 120 ans cette
année encore plus d'une centaine de
modèles exposés dont une quarantaine de
premières mondiales malgré l'absence
remarquée de fiat volkswagen ou encore
alfa romeo le public pourra apprécier le
qatar restylée ou encore les nouveaux
modèles de citroën
nous retrouverons aussi lors de cette
édition à saint quentin en yvelines pour
évoquer la performance attendue du
collectif tout d'abord elle du jumpstyle
sur la scène du théâtre de saint quentin
en yvelines ce sera de la culture et
puis comme chaque vendredi l'essentiel
de la semaine les principaux sujets qui
ont fait l'actualité ce sera en seconde
partie d'émission
[Musique]
e
pour son 120e anniversaire le salon de
l'automobile de paris fait donc peau
neuve nouveau nom le pari motor show
nouvelle orientation avec une ouverture
vers les nouvelles technologies et puis
également la verve le deux roues un
choix dicté par une fréquentation en
légère diminution l'année dernière mais
aussi par la volonté de certains
constructeurs de privilégier d'autres
salons comme genève shanghai ou encore
pékin quoi qu'il en soit le pari encore
chaud 2018 elle devrait accueillir un
peu plus d'un million de visiteurs
jusqu'au 14 octobre
[Musique]
oui
plus de 150 entreprises de l'automobile
sont présentes dans le département à des
yvelines dont renault pour son site de
production mais aussi son centre de
recherche et de développement le
technocentre à guyancourt
le constructeur présente cette année au
mondial 2018 ah non pas sa clio 5
pourtant très attendu mais un cas déjà
restylée un qadjar lancé voici trois ans
et qui souffre toujours de la
concurrence du 3008 de peugeot
l'extérieur vous le voyez change peu
avec cette calandre beaucoup plus
affirmée pour l'intérieur on remarquera
une nouvelle console centrale entre
autres et puis pour le moteur ce sera un
peu plus musclé avec le 1 2 litre cette
blouse dci de 150 chevaux
mais la principale de curiosité sur le
centre de renault c'est un concept car
un nouveau concept car 100 % électrique
100% autonome vous allez le découvrir
c'est li zhi ultime au lisier ultimo
pour voyager dans son salon mais un
salon pour le moins luxueux
votre constructeur très présent dans le
département des yvelines c'est peugeot
qui présente plusieurs de ces nouveautés
ici la 508 et puis aussi de nouvelles
motorisations bonjour merci de nous
recevoir ici sur votre votre stand
bonjour c'est avec grand plaisir faisons
un petit point sur les nouveautés que
vous présenter ici là nous sommes devant
les hybrides notamment nouvelle
motorisation pour vos véhicules
alors oui c'est vrai nous présentons ici
et bien nous nouvelle motorisation
hybride rechargeable donc ce sont des
motorisations qu'on va déployer sur nos
modèles 508 berline 508 sw et 3008
on va proposer une motorisation qui va
permettre à nos clients de rouler
pendant 40 et jusqu'à 50 km en mode zéro
émission donc très intéressant au
quotidien évidemment un trajet domicile
travail se fera dans une journée sans
dépenser un euro décence et à la verse
sur un week-end ou en vacances et bien
le client pourra utiliser toute la la
modularité de l'essence combiné avec
l'électrique donc de faire des longs
trajets donc c'est une grande liberté
qu'on offre à nos clients des émissions
de co2 très maîtrisée on parle de 49 g
ça veut dire à peu près 2 litre en
moyenne
vous voyez donc c'est une vraie une
vraie rupture et tout ça avec des
puissants ce sympathique puisque on est
sur des voitures qui vont de 225 à 300
chevaux vous voyez avec de vrais
prestations et en plus sur le 3008 un
mode 4 4 qui permettra à nos clients se
sortir de toutes les situations un peu
difficile avec une disponibilité à
partir de corps alors ces voitures
seront commercialisés à partir de
septembre 2019 donc à partir de l'année
prochaine voilà et on va déployer
progressivement cette motorisation sur
les trois voitures que j'ai cités il ya
une vraie demande aujourd'hui justement
pour ces hybrides pour une recherche de
nouvelles énergies ou est-ce que ça
reste encore un début de marche et alors
c'est un début de marché mais en même
temps on a tous assisté à la baisse du
diesel on voit bien que de plus en plus
le mix comme on dit diesel est en train
de tomber et donc nous on est en train
de chercher des solutions alternatives
au diesel est clairement cette ce type
de motorisation
c'est une alternative au diesel parce
que vous êtes sur des consommations qui
sont base parce que vous êtes sur des
voitures polyvalente en termes d' usage
et puis parce que à la fin en terme
notamment pour les entreprises qui
louent beaucoup de ces voitures là on va
être sur des loyers qui vont être très
comparables à ceux d un diesel dont vous
voyez une offre qui est très très
complémentaire de ce qu'on a
et puis en même temps qu'ils y pallier
cette baisse du diesel qui propose des
prestations de premier ordre à nos
clients on peut faire peut-être un petit
mot sur le concept car qui est présenté
ici qui est 100% électrique et autonome
aussi c'est là aussi l'avenir le
véhicule autonome oui alors bien sûr
l'avenir bon par tous du véhicule
autonome et puis du véhicule électrique
bien sûr il est là alors sur ce concept
car qui s'appelle le peugeot y légende
ce qu'on a voulu faire c'est à la fois
aller puiser dans les racines de la
marque dans le passé de la marque
puisque cette voiture est inspiré de la
504 de la fameuse glorieuse 504 et donc
c'est vraiment très important pour nous
de réactiver ses gènes de la marque
parce que évidemment une marque à deux
cents ans d'histoire
il faut qu'on en parle et puis ça évoque
des tas de souvenirs je suis sûre chez
d'état de téléspectateurs et en même
temps se projette vers le futur parce
que sur cette voiture ont proposé une
voiture qui est 100% électrique et qui
est 100% autonome c'est-à-dire que en
mode conduite autonome
le client pourra faire autre chose tout
simplement que conduire leur volant va
glisser sous le tableau de bord de
grands écrans vont apparaître
et le client pourra regarder un film
travail et enfin faire ce qu'il a envie
de faire ça fait rêver ce genre de
véhicule mais est ce qu'on peut
l'imaginer sur la route bientôt un loup
ce qui nous intéresse tout d'abord c'est
de voir un peu les réactions que cela
suscite alors les vôtres bien sûr qu'ils
se des clients
on veut comprendre ce que donne cette
association entre l'histoire et le futur
notre vision du futur qu'est ce que les
gens pensent ça sert à ça sert à ça
avant tout un concept car et puis après
évidemment on a beaucoup de gens qui
nous disaient pourquoi il faudrait il
faudrait la faire elle est super rebelle
nous aussi on a envie de plein de choses
après on a des impératifs économiques
donc déjà analysons ce que les clients
nous en dise et après on se projettera
peut-être vers des étapes ultérieures
avant de poursuivre ce 7,8 hebdo
majoritairement consacrée aux paris
motor show 2018 nous allons revenir sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines avec de la culture et la
représentation du collectif la horde sur
la scène nationale ce week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le calme avant la tempête les danseurs
de tout d'abord amène le public dans
leur art de john style né dans les
années 90 en hollande
des performances fait de saut de
quelques secondes qui ont inspiré le
collectif la horde voir des jeunes
garçons parce qu'il ya très peu de
filles dans la communauté s'est exprimé
comme ça sur les réseaux sur internet se
réapproprier leur corps alors que
souvent ils sont dans des îles sont en
tout cas isolé d'institutions
culturelles et donc ici s'émancipe se
réapproprient leur corps pour faire un
art qu'est la danse
et c'est cette rage cette exaltation qui
nous a tout de suite fasciné avec marina
jonathan depuis 2014 le collectif
explore cette discipline un film des
performances et une création
chorégraphique tout d'abord une heure de
danse survoltée tout d'abord c'est un
clin d'oeil aline hardcore qui me dira
record tout d'abord donc hardcore
jusqu'à l'os et qui a renoué que nos
accords
les danseurs ils sont onze tous
autodidactes et européens pour la
plupart avec tout d'abord ils sont
passés des réseaux sociaux à la scène de
la danse individuelle au groupe
la plupart des danseurs sont droitiers
et quand je suis arrivé pour danser avec
les autres danseurs j'étais gaucher
nôtres et fallu réapprendre avancé de
l'autre côté donc ça a été très
difficile
vous avez plusieurs pas de base et vous
avez plusieurs mouvements clefs qui
reviennent en fait ce qui établit une
espèce de base commune de pourri jumper
et ces mouvements là en fait et ba par
exemple en france sur les appels d'un
certain nombre en pologne l'a
certainement russie pour eux le pas de
base le plus utilisé n'est pas le même
qu'en france des différences qui se
reflète sur scène avec urgence et une
certaine fureur de vivre
mais le collectif laisse parfois la
place à l'individualité avec une énergie
plus douce mais contagieuse
bmw qui en 2020 va regrouper ses
activités sur montigny le bretonneux
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
bien évidemment mais c'est une bonne
occasion pour s'arrêter sur leur stand
pour ce mondial de l'auto à 2018 bonjour
à vous et on va faire un petit tour
d'horizon de vos nouveautés et il ya
notamment pour vous cette série 3
absolument bmw présente pas moins de
sept nouveautés sur ce mondial de l'auto
à paris
à commencer par cette nouvelle bmw série
3 7e génération d'un modèle du modèle
iconique de la marque bmw quelques
années en arrière un peu plus de 40 ans
1975 lorsque la première benne ou les
série 3 est apparue et depuis plus de 15
millions de modèles vendus ça reste la
voiture premium la plus vendue dans le
monde
et donc cette septième génération et
bien réinterprète c'est la quintessence
de la berline sportive puisque c'est le
le l'adn est l'essence de la bmo et
série3 avec un design évidemment qu'ils
expriment ce dynamisme
un gros travail a porté également sur le
châssis pour une conduite toujours plus
sportive et des sensations de conduite
très forte qui sont aussi pour une
grande part dans le plaisir de conduire
traditionnel de bmw est également
beaucoup de connectivité beaucoup de
nouveaux équipements technologiques en
particulier 1
un assistant personnel intelligent qui
sera proposée sur cette bmw série 3 qui
permettra en fait aux conducteurs est
bien d'échanger de dialoguer directement
avec sa voiture
concernant les équipements de sa voiture
concernant la façon dont il peut les
utiliser
et concernant également son voyage pour
avoir une recommandation de restaurant
pour pouvoir mettre une ambiance un peu
plus relaxante si par exemple le
producteur est stressé la voiture va
pouvoir échanger pour pouvoir affiner
les besoins du conducteur est évidemment
évoluer faire évoluer l'habitacle en
fonction des besoins et en intelligence
à une petite démonstration tout à
l'heure c'est d'ores et déjà
opérationnels justement ce système tout
à fait cette opé rationnel absolument
sur un certain nombre de fonctions et la
grosse force de ceux de ce système c'est
que c'est
du match in learning comme on dit c'est
à dire que peu à peu le système va
apprendre un petit peu vos habitudes vos
aux us et coutumes et pouvoir vous
recommander des choses qui sont de plus
en plus en phase avec vos attentes sur
les autres nouveautés les six autres
nouveautés vous présenter ici quelles
sont celles qui se démarque le plus
peut-être alors dans les première
mondiale puisque on part on parle de
cela il y a bien sûr la nouvelle bmw x5
qui est présenté ici pour la première
fois au public donc quatrième génération
de ce modèle également emblématique
puisque x5 est devenue en quelques
années la référence des suivait
familiaux sera inauguré pour un d'année
prochaine sur ce x5 une version hybride
rechargeable également et donc le x5 à
vocation aujourd'hui à proposer des
capacités en tout chemin encore
supérieur à la génération précédente et
on pourra découvrir sa très
prochainement clients et clients
immédiats d'ailleurs au cours des
prochains essais ensuite sur ce salon on
retrouve également la nouvelle bmw z4
alors il ya une preview au moment de
pebble beach mais la vraie première
mondiale grand public
c'est ici à paris alors le z4 c'est une
histoire de passion puisque vous le
savez bmw une tradition de roadster qui
est bien établi un des modèles qui sont
devenus iconiques comme la bmw 507 comme
la bmw z1 et nous les aidons 8 et ce
n'est pour citer seulement certains
exemples est effectivement aujourd'hui
on arrive avec cette troisième
génération de z4 centré autour du
plaisir de conduire alors on retrouve
évidemment les attributs du roadster par
excellence c'est à dire une capote en
toile
un très long capot
un empattement également très très grand
et chez bmw sur les roadsters la
tradition c'est d'avoir mis le
conducteur au centre de la voiture est
évidemment toujours toujours en
propulsion et on retrouve évidemment cet
esprit très sportif grâce à un travail
qui a été prêt à porter très travaillé
sur le châssis une très grande rigidité
également de la carrosserie ce qui est
important sur un sur un cabriolet et des
motorisations qui vont 297 à 340 chevaux
[Musique]
chaque semaine dans l'hebdo nous
revenons sur les sujets qui ont marqué l
actualité dans les yvelines et malgré
cette édition spéciale mondial de l'auto
nous ne changeons pas cette habitude de
regarder un contact direct et pas
seulement par courrier 18 entreprises et
deux organismes de formation aux
participer à ce job dating coup de pouce
pour l'emploi le deuxième organisé à la
verrière en début d'opération tous les
recruteurs se présente devant l'ensemble
des candidats déjà ça leur permet de
voir qu'ils vont avoir en face d'eux et
ensuite c'est une rencontre qui
fonctionne ou non mais on en dit plus
sur soi quand on rencontre une personne
qu'avec un simple cv auxiliaire de vie
agents de recouvrement techniciens de
maintenance
les postes proposés sont pour des débuts
de carrière sans qualification à bac + 2
j'aime bien voir autre chose ça lorsque
quelqu un qui moi personnellement j'aime
bien essayer d'autres choses dans la vie
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant de démarcher dans ce genre
de concept parce que déjà les
ceux qui font les employeurs ils
viennent directement nous nous voir ils
nous proposent ils nous font un listing
sur leurs entreprises 92 jeunes de 18 à
35 ans se sont présentées dans les
yvelines les moins de 49 ans était près
de 50000 au chômage au deuxième
trimestre 2010 8
[Musique]
maman tu
la plus belle du monde
aucune autre à laon
le mardi après midi dans les locaux des
restos du coeur de rambouillet les
coupes sanchez
la gérante du salon sourire diam's a
contacté l'association il ya trois ans
pour proposer ses services
deux séances ponctuelles elle est passée
cette année un créneau hebdomadaire
consacrée aux bénéficiaires il ya des
personnes qui aident avec des dons il ya
des personnes qui aident financièrement
et puis moi je voulais vraiment aider
avec notre savoir faire car je pars
vraiment sur le principe que être beau
pour un entretien est beau tout les
jours ben ça redonne confiance en soi et
c'est aussi ma façon dont collaboré aux
citoyens de rambouillet l'une de ses
employées vient tous les mardis de 14 à
16 heures pour quoi faire en moyenne
seuls bénéficiaires gratuitement
raccourcir la longueur la mort la neige
habitué aux séances rico du mardi
après-midi organisé par le resto du
coeur de rambouillet marie laure a cette
fois décidé de passer entre les mains
d'audrey un moment pour soi idéal pour
se sentir en confiance avant son
prochain entretien en bouche on perd
beaucoup son emploi au pied autre chose
et qu'on est dans une situation jusqu'à
aller aux restos du coeur
ça veut dire qu mais financièrement on
n'y arrive plus belle image de soi c'est
très très important et toujours on
sourit
pour la famille pour nous mêmes les
bénéficiaires sont ravis d'avoir accès à
ce service et les sciences coiffure
daudré sont déjà complètes
jusqu'au mois de novembre
[Musique]
le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines est entré dans une nouvelle
dimension et que cette ryder cup 2018 sa
tribune de 6800 places installé au
départ du trou numéro 1 marqué
l'histoire de la compétition en devenant
la plus grande infrastructure jamais
construite pour une ryder cup des
frissons des frissons et des frais sans
un vrai stade de sport un vrai stade de
foot de basket de le stade de france de
golf c'est vraiment impressionnant c'est
grand déjà et il c'est grandiose
l'ambiance est géniale il ya énormément
nombre il y à des lieux rock qui courent
d'un côté des seuils de l'autre est un
oui c'est grandiose voilà on peut pas
dire qu'elle ne se soit pas vous c'est
un grand succès français fait tribune
ensoleillé ça veut tout dire ça fait un
peu la france la zone du roi soleil on
n'est pas loin de versailles le parcours
a également été plébiscité par les
supporters et les joueurs des deux camps
préparé pendant plus de deux ans avant
le début de la compétition pour un coût
de 7 5 millions d'euros
il est aujourd'hui considéré comme l'un
des meilleurs au monde où tant de
travail des années des sacrifices les
work et voilà tout s'est bien passé
l'image que la presse nationale et
monétaire s'explique c'est super c'est
sûr il comptait six très fiers te fait
d'aimer cqib et voilà comment s'est
passé le golf national va maintenant
retrouver une activité plus
classiquement les prochains mois avant
d'organiser une nouvelle compétition
planétaire dans six ans les jeux
olympiques de 2024
[Musique]
la ryder cup passé on pense déjà à la
suite dans les yvelines la fédération
française de golf la direction des
services de l'éducation nationale et les
élus ont inauguré lundi deux nouvelles
sections golf dans les collèges de
nouvelles classes qui répondent à la
logique de démocratisation de la
discipline lancée dès 2008 nous étions
un peu dans un paradoxe finalement dans
le département avec près de 32 sites
golfique et puis aucune section sportive
scolaire
donc aujourd'hui nous en sommes à deux
nous comptons évidemment prolonger cette
dynamique
le golfeur professionnel français
michaël lorenzo vera est le parrain de
ces sections yvelinoise une quarantaine
de collégiens de tous les niveaux
peuvent dès à présent bénéficier de
trois heures de golf par semaine une
autre athlète est champion de golf de
demain sont là et lorsque je vois ces
jeunes naturellement avoir un bon swing
de golf taper dans la balle avec
beaucoup de naturel je suis content
qu'ils découvrent enfin notre sport
avant d'en faire des champions
l'objectif est surtout de démocratiser
la pratique la section sportive leur
ouvre la voie à la licence unss des
heures d'entraînement supplémentaire le
mercredi pour les plus motivés et des
compétitions cd avec dans l'ensemble
sont assez attentif et qui ont envie de
progresser parce que c'est vraiment
basée sur la motivation est parti au
moment où on avait motivé je veux dire
il réussit plus vite que n'importe quel
autre élève l'éducation nationale s'est
fixé pour objectif l'ouverture de 4000
sections sportives supplémentaires dans
toute la france d'ici 2024
[Musique]
voilà pour l'actualité des yvelines et
pour le reste de l'ile-de-france c'est
avec nos confrères de via grand paris et
cette semaine un reportage sur la
fashion week de paris
textile maroquinerie cosmétiques ou
encore joaillerie l'industrie de la mode
en france représente 150 milliards
d'euros c'est plus que l'automobile et
l'aéronautique réuni ce résultat il
s'explique par les exportations
réalisées par les 50 premières
entreprises françaises
80% des ventes se font à l'étranger
pourrait parler de french touch on n'en
parle plus tôt en musique qu'en mode ou
le nom de secteurs d'activité mais
effectivement on a de bonnes écoles à
paris on a de grandes maisons qui aussi
forme des créateurs qui à terme montrons
leur propre activité donc il ya sept
cet écosystème aussi dont on peut parler
à paris qui fait que cette industrie est
aussi importante pour les communes
françaises
point d'orgue de cette dynamique
économique la fashion week à paris avec
ses défilés haute couture c'est 27 salon
professionnel et ses quatorze mille
exposants
c'est la grande messe de la mode les
retombées économiques sont colossales
plus de 10,3 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires
c'est un événement qui compte pour la
vie et communiquent à paris
qui se développe bien puisque paris a
aussi la chance d'être un centre
d'attraction pour beaucoup de créateurs
internationaux
c'est la fashion week la plus
internationale au monde donc on a des
japonais des libanais des américains qui
viennent présenter leurs collections à
paris et tout ça pour le plus grand
bénéfice des entreprises locales
aujourd'hui en france la mode représente
1,7 pour cent du pib soit près d'un
million d'emplois
le journal revient à lundi à 18h en
direct avec grégory et à canal et en
attendant on se quitte avec un aperçu
des plus belles voitures présentées ici
à paris a jusqu'au 14 octobre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]